kristen wiig and you
were in the groundlings and you were in
the groundlings for nine years maybe
probably like 12. it's where i met my
ben my husband isn't that crazy like for
12 years that's almost like sometimes
you're too long at the party right i
mean oh yeah yeah like 12 years you were
probably getting discouraged right
because you want to get out of the
groundlings at some point and sort of
get into something a tv show or a film
right i mean that's the goal yeah i had
a weird situation i was i was doing a
show that ran like i i got a show that
ran for seven years
so i actually was
working but you know it wasn't in i
could never leave groundlings because i
i need i wanted first i wanted a live
audience and then
it was kind of like where will i wear my
weird wigs is it fun to be in the ground
i love it i loved every minute of it so
kristen because she knew you from the
groundlings when she got the movie
bridesmaids she said to you why don't
you come audition yeah annie mumlow who
she wrote it with kristin that she
actually called and said will you come
in tomorrow
and i was like oh yeah
and they send you the pages
send me the pages i came in and i
improvised with kristen so so it was
improv it wasn't the script that you did
with her we did parts of the script but
i'd known kristen for so we'd known each
other for so long that
once we we would start the script and
then either she would float or i would
kind of float away and then the next
thing we're talking about
sex with a dolphin and sex with the
dolphin specifically you went into some
sort of bit where and you probably
didn't even have a plan but you went
into what it would be like to give a
hand job to a dolphin right no i think i
said gentle something about gent i think
it started with the cruise ship stuff
that i'd taken a trip and then we
started improvising that fell overboard
and i said i spent 45 minutes underwater
and she said how is it possible and i
said something about like his hand the
dolphin's hands were so soft there was
hand play yeah i was like i'm not going
to say rape because it wasn't because it
was like it was really really
horrible and when i left i wanted to
like punch myself in there because you
said like where did that come from right
you were like i don't think about
dolphins and [ __ ] dolphins and hand
jobs for dolphins
sometimes when you're that you go for
anything that'll get a laugh and i swear
paul and judd's face it was not like the
room was like oh this is awesome i think
it was more just like shock
and so you get no feedback right after
that they were super nice but i mean it
was so weird that i just thought it's
like okay goodbye thank you yeah thanks
how long is that audition how long have
thanks freak how long is that audition
i don't know maybe i was in there 15
minutes
maybe 20 minutes
and when do you find out you get the
movie bridesmaid i think i found out the
next day oh i think and you were shocked
i was
like totally shocked i was like for the
same part yeah or i thought it'd be like
walking by with a tray like hello ma'am
but it was a defining part i mean it was
just i mean it was belly laugh funny and
you know in most comedies
you don't really have hard hard laughs
like that it's hard to get those laughs
i think that script kind of crushed it
and then they they just cast i mean
everybody in it was really
funny your character's so bold and
brassy in that in that movie
and yet the movie was written a whole
different way it was written that you
were supposed to be meek and sort of
sheepish right i just read i think i
just read it wrong i really i i didn't
it wasn't some brilliant move on your
part no i must have for some reason when
i read it that's that's what i saw did
you ad-lib a lot of scenes in that movie
yeah we had we we improvised a lot i
heard that there was a scene in there
that you ad-libbed that you talked about
a squirrel coming out of your vagina or
something like that is that true it's
really possible yeah yeah
you just let it go right and you leave
it up to them to show you you did so
much you don't even remember no that's
really sad you said a squirrel had
burrowed into your vagina and was living
inside of you and you they have it on
film somewhere jesus really yeah
you don't remember that no which is
equally
disturbing that i wouldn't be like i'll
never forget saying that
but i understand that you don't remember
that i mean like i go on the radio four
hours a day i don't remember a [ __ ]
thing i said after i leave and this
woman says you said this i said i did i
don't know
i think it's like when you're loose and
you just you just kind of say it and
you're trying to please an audience yeah
i think i i think you know especially in
the character it's like if you're just
especially if you're just trying to get
as much out and that character was so
overwhelming that she just she just
talked and talked and told weird
detailed stories and they would they
would take
terrible turds